[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Sakia and
very excited to be talking about
evolutionary anthropology talking about
the far future we have GA Gokul ero
joining us on the show hello alright
hello thanks for coming on very excited
very grateful that we met at June's
event last weekend that was a really
great event such a good event I just
have to shout out I mean this book so
good interested in capital isn't such a
good book highly recommend everyone
check it out we just had our enos m on
the show last night oh really
so we're hey yeah with just another you
know young 19 year old Stanford super
smart as well it's just such a good
community of people very grateful that
we ended up meeting and having good
conversation and now we're here to talk
for those that don't know we have some
background on GA go
so GA go is a philosopher ease and
evolute evolutionary anthropologist in
training you're doing so much writing
three papers right now we're gonna be
breaking down and this all in ten topics
very excited we'd like to start things
off with this big history perspective on
society what is your current take on the
state of humanity right so I guess my
current take it has to somewhat
contradictory elements on the one hand
it seems that you know poverty is as
down as its ever have been technologies
is rising you can get pretty good
picture of that in Hans Rosling book
about you know the statistics of how the
world has been folding in a very
desirable way let's say in the last one
hundred and something years and I agree
with all that and on the same on the
other hand it seems to me that we are
not considering many possible avenues
that could be inducing us closer to some
sort of societal collapse or some sort
of trouble and I think one of the ways
in which I'm slightly different from
most of the thinkers and people who are
around here in the Bay Area
to reasonable these things is that I
lean on a more you know let's make sure
that even in these cases were that's
what's actually going to unfold that's
what's actually going to manifest we
still create an awesome future later
down the road so that's that's been my
perspective I guess so I think we're
we're as good as we've ever been but are
not necessarily on an upward trend you
know it might we might be on the very
peak so that's basically my take yeah
ooh so so it's important to see then
that a trajectory may not like you said
may be at a peak and then maybe on an
angle of declination potentially after
that so the moment in time although it
may look fantastic we don't actually
know which way it's going after so right
what one thing that I wrote on I wrote
on a Facebook post a while ago was a big
difference that people can that I've
observed in the reasoning in the
cognition of people who are more
left-leaning and more right leaning
among the people who are more
intellectual like both sides
intellectuals is that the left-leaning
people tend to rely more on statistics
and the projection and extrapolation of
graphs whereas the right leaning people
they tend to be more focused on
narratives and these point these
invariants points these points where
there is a big shift
you know let's say there's a graph
that's moving up something is getting to
up to 30% but then at a 30% point you
expect something to differ dramatically
so I guess the most classical example is
people discuss a lot about demographics
is there consequential historical
reasons to expect you know if
demographics changed as much what are
going to be the consequences down the
road you know if different numbers of
single mothers exist for in for instance
or if the racial distribution of a group
is different if the cultural
distribution is different usually the
more liberal people will be more
interesting to just extrapolating the
curve and being excited about it because
I mean it's it's it's worth being
excited about on the other hand you know
sometimes these things will change
the narrative and then the whole system
kind of reorganizes itself this seems a
little bit like what Peter teal was just
discussing when he said that the Google
narrative in Silicon Valley is that this
is happening all the time and that feels
like well why haven't we solved cancer
you know why are some of the
intellectual community stalling out in
some of the ways and and so this is a
very interesting conversation to have is
what is actually right a trajectory and
how do we participate in making the
trajectory beautiful right that's right
I've there's these two monsters I think
there are Lovecraftian monsters that
people use in order to make analogies
for evolution and for problems in in
game theory in the rationalist community
in the affect of autism community and
among Bay Area people which are as a
thought which should be a representative
of the idea of evolution itself and
Moloch which is a representation of you
know all the things that if each
individual acts according to their
self-interest might end up going bad
right so sometimes a system is organized
in that way the university system might
be a system that has a problem in that
way so when when the brexit stuff
happened when Trump happened I posted
thinking about these two systems that so
far the evolutionary forces had been
curbed for a really long time at least
since the Industrial Revolution and it
was mostly like the problems that we
were trying to solve with technology the
problems we were trying to solve with
culture were the problems of individual
incentives and how to make things like
faster and more functional between
different people so most of our problems
were Moloch type and I think that we've
we've moved from these game theoretical
problems back into a more survivalist
state were you know with Peter T Oh with
Tyler : who conceptualized things that
way
I think we've eaten most of the
low-hanging fruit and now the forces
that are going to be controlling a lot
of what happens in the earth like the
big moving forces are going to be more
based off evolution and survival and
less about like game theory and the the
reorganization of incentives and things
like that so in that sense you know if
we have if we've actually reached this
peak of academic economic development
and of how easy it is to acquire new
technologies then we might expect that
there will be a little bit more of you
know we might end up electing someone
who lived in a zero-sum market his
entire career such as Donna Trump right
so that's that's a reflection it seems
to me of becoming zero-sum whereas we
were positive some for a really long
time yeah and so the main part of of
what we want to see the growth is the
pie that's growing a positive sum over
and over and over again and that like
you indicated this may have been a
potentially a moment of zero-sum
realization and that ranging culture in
so many ways and changing information
technology and yeah if you think of even
like the slogans that were running at
the time right like the idea of and not
only in the previous election right
improves the election there was the idea
of America first it assumes that well if
we're not gonna grow all together then
we might as well like let our side of
the pie grow and I guess now you know if
I've been watching a lot of the yangyang
stuff yeah and Andrew Angus candidacy
and it's kind of the same idea right
it's like okay so we want to have a
redistributed policy because it's not
clear that normal people write your own
book or the world or normal people yes
yeah and it's not clear that there's
going to be a way for a way for growing
the pie constantly in all of its parts
therefore should you distribute it maybe
you know so I think that it's important
to consider this possibility that the
technological trend is is on a peak and
maybe going down and then is it
potential also that then the ones that
are already and maybe the top of the SES
socioeconomic status that own a lot of
the production already that are owning a
lot of the robotics manufacturing
already drone manufacturing already are
intelligence algorithmic drive of you
know things like the social media
networks that we use and everything that
maybe that the production the reap the
rewards of the production for them is
just going to be significantly greater
than for the normal people that and that
that's what we see with the GDP
increasing while median mail income
stagnates and so that's a major issue is
is this stagnation or even declination
for normal people and that that causes
instability in a civilization and that's
bad news yeah there's a there's an
evolutionary anthropologist to study
that wrote a book about basically how
inequality special inequality among men
it tends to be a strong driver of
violence and a strong driver I think is
called killing the competition it's
basically a driver for young male
violence and for a young male you know
in general like instability there's ways
of trying to solve this instability you
know people have tried video games
some people take on drugs it's unclear
where we should you know steer meaning
meaning is a very important vaccination
delivering the proper nutrients that
every seedling their birth into the
world having a strong social fabric etc
okay tell us about you know we're gonna
touch on this as we keep going but tell
us about you know growing up in Brazil
and getting fascinated with evolutionary
anthropology how did this all get
started right well growing up in Brazil
I was born in Sao Paulo and it's a very
big city so it's a cosmopolitan city I
was always fascinated ever since I had
my first class and survival of the
fittest about convolution and there's
been basically two topics that
fascinated me my entire life which are
you know in any given topic that you
tell me I'm usually going to get closer
within the topic to like evolution in
some way so what evolves that is related
to the thing you're talking about or
about minds so you know evolutionary
anthropology and evolutionary psychology
which are very related fields they're
basically the union of these two main
attractors right my main intellectual
tractor is my whole life
mean to understand better what the mind
is how the mind works where does it come
from and to understand evolutionary
systems and in which ways did they
develop in which way should we expect
them to unfold over time so I stayed in
Brazil for a long time I did philosophy
for the most part because the smartest
professors in my university turned out
to be the people in philosophy I started
doing psychology and then I transferred
because I wanted to be you know wherever
the intellectual edge was and my
university it was in the philosophy
department I ended up writing a book
about the philosopher Daniel Dennett who
is an evolutionary thinker and a
philosopher of mind so he likes the same
stuff I do basically and yeah and I
ended up kind of thinking that
philosophy is going to run a little bit
stagnant in the in the next few decades
in philosophy of mind in particular and
it wasn't going to solve some of the
questions that I still had it had
already solved a lot of the questions I
had before therefore I felt like trying
something new and I found professor
Torrance Deakin is my adviser and he he
studies evolutionary anthropology and
neuroscience and he had a very different
perspective but still involving you know
mines and evolution these two topics
that I really appreciate so a lot of
this started with you having an
appreciation for seeing you survival of
the fittest and seeing it not only like
Darwinian evolution kind of as part of
humanity but also just a obsession with
how the mind is molded through this
process as well how it evolves through
culture how gets influenced and then
kind of melding the the evolutionary
anthropology with psychology right I
guess apart in part that's because I'm
an intuitive immortal list so I've
always wanted to live as long as
possible and I guess the idea of
survival of the fittest is fairly
connected and my interest in philosophy
of mind my interest in understanding how
Minds works
and the associated areas was basically
stemming in part from okay so it seems
that I am this kind of system is there a
way to preserve this system over time in
a way there will be robust and valuable
yeah you know yeah but I would yell and
has a good quote on that which is you
know I don't I don't want to be immortal
through my work I want to be immortal
through not dying and a lot of me wanted
to you know it seems to figure out
through evolution through philosophy of
mind in which ways is it possible to
stabilize Minds over time most of that
quest I think I've I've let go of but
I'm still interested in stabilizing
values and stabilizing like ethical
systems and values over the very long
run and I would say that that's
basically the thing that compels me and
has compelled me for the past few years
in my work stabilizing ethical systems
and values making sure that whatever
happens in the future you know is still
something that we would consider very
valuable or or even that you know we
can't even anticipate but that it's
still you know desirable yes yeah so
then it's as though the keeping the the
ethics the values that has made
civilization great keeping that code
making sure that it continues moving
forward and becoming better so that way
we ensure that positive and future right
and especially because at least you know
I'm in part a utilitarian right I like
to tell people that everyone has a part
that they're selfish and a part of their
altruistic yeah the part of me that is
altruistic is a utilitarian right and
wants to maximize the amount of good
that happens in the entire course of
history so a lot of my my thoughts go in
that direction and that basically means
that that requires for civilization to
go on for the possibility of its
expansion into space for the creation of
minds that will align in their interests
and interconnect in amazing
transformative different ways that we
you have hitler'd a lot seen you get to
the edge of knowledge explore what goes
past our edge of knowledge make new
great and protocols that maximize the
flourishing of new minds yeah yeah
so so then you know from there then how
did you get brought into the Berkeley
ecosystem yeah right so the the
transitioning factor was I was already
interested in utilitarianism and
basically I wanted to figure out you
know after let's say after my main quest
stop being trying to seek for personal
immortality
it became let's figure out you know how
to make the world the best possible
world for the maximum amount of minds
over the largest course of time and
there were other people in the world who
were interested in the same thing who
were also young and kind of excited and
connecting themselves through the
internet and those people ended up
becoming what later was the effective
altruism movement right so this was
before it had a name but I connected
with some of those people and I created
the first transhumanist and effective
altruism related institution in Brazil
and I directed it for a while it's still
ongoing they're still you know a few
people there for a little while we had
like 25 people organizing a think-tank
promoting things I was you know
interviewed with magazines a bunch of
other things so so that was my entering
on this world that later became
effective altruism through my
utilitarianism and and the two main hubs
in the world for that were Oxford and
Berkeley and I decided because I'm
Brazilian and Oxford is really cold and
it snowed to have a hard time there and
I also have a hippie side of me and I
like dancing that I would be much better
off by trying to come to Berkeley than
Oxford that's basically why I applied to
Berkeley okay and then now since you've
been at Berkeley and what what has been
you know you you were teaching me about
this and you were teaching us about this
earlier you need see with all of the
potential of where civilization can go
and you see that there is a potential
for this you know this non super
intelligence future and right even
though the super intelligence future
looks like it's quite likely that we're
going in that direction what if it's
actually several hundred years later
than well we're
so how can we ensure that the
civilization the values and the ethics
of that civilization go forth so I think
the reason why a lot of people are
driven especially Bay Area tech people
are driven to the idea of a single area
the idea of super intelligence is it's
on the one hand it's very exciting and
on the other hand it kind of relieves
one from some obligations that we use to
have if evolution right so more
conservative people feel like they have
more familial obligations they feel like
they have obligations to their nation a
bunch of things that they were born
already having more adventurous
left-leaning
innovative people will want there to be
a new potential technology that releases
them from all these tangential
discomforts let's say so let me draw one
parallel here and then I'll go back to
that I think one interesting person who
did an experiment in thinking about how
the future is going to be without making
this assumption of okay there would be a
super intelligence and it will generate
very valuable things was Robin Hanson
when he wrote the age of M and the idea
there is okay let's limit things that
about human intelligence but let's
change actually the way in which this
intelligence reproduces so the main
thing that that he created was okay if
we can actually reproduce labor fairly
quickly by creating virtual brains that
you can literally replicate by copying a
program how would the economy be
transformed then how would society be
transformed I think this is an extremely
valuable exercise because this is one
possible Avenue of the future right so I
love the bostrom type exercise where you
extrapolate super intelligence
I love the the Robin Hanson exercise
where you extrapolate what happens if
replication gets cheaper and we still
haven't at our level of intelligence but
I thought to myself ok who is actually
doing the exercise of what if neither of
those two transformative technologies
comes to be to fruition we still want to
create the awesome future for as many
people as possible so let's take how
evolution
has been unfolding so far biologically
and culturally and what how it has led
us to the point where we are now and
then extrapolate in which direction
evolution seems to be going and see to
what extent we can steer that movement
in in a desirable direction and that's
revolutionary anthropology comes in
because it's the study of populations
societies and cultures and the ways in
which they've interacted and in which
they were you know had more of your
children went war didn't go to war build
a wall didn't build a wall made open
borders you know the all sorts of
transformations which so far have guided
the course of history and like maybe
someone should be thinking about how to
do that
like how how would the world look like
and what to do if the next 2,000 years
are kind of like the last 2,000 years
you know and there's very few
utilitarians are very few very people
excited about that so that's a good
point yeah yeah the the we we definitely
have a strong proclivity to feel like
we're at the super intelligence is just
you know 50 or 100 years like these are
our numbers it's happening this
generation and everything and it's just
like it's kind of being driven forth by
by Silicon Valley in many ways this
narrative but at the same time the
narrative of how do we ensure that if
civilization is like it's been the last
thousand years for the next thousand
years how do we have a stable growth of
our ethics and morals this is very very
important to discuss right one thing
that I think it just seems to be lacking
you know in these big urban centers that
aggregated some of the smartest people
in the world it's basically like no one
is thinking of hey what if the method by
which we create new intelligences in the
future continues to be via sex and
babies yeah yeah no one is thinking
about that it's it's kind of crazy I
mean no one no one has more utilitarian
yet and the whole pose of religion about
it but in their fans family sex babies
keeping this you know family ties
community ties really really strong and
powerful is something that I the you
know I'm excited for you to touch on a
little bit later in our
our conversation what is you know I read
your post about the Christianity
superorganism and you had a video but
yes who teach us about this two billion
people around the world are there those
are all two billion people who are
Christian yeah both about the same
number like the Muslims past the
Christian is not that long ago so when I
started examining what's going on from
this evolutionary perspective with no
transformation of technologies I guess
the first thing you wonder is okay who
is growing as a fraction of the
population who is diminishing as a
fraction of the population and
interestingly enough religion aside
right if you just look at the different
nations there's been a very interesting
transformation where the people who
would eventually migrate to the cities
where most of the information transfer
is happening between Intel intelligent
people let's say in the USA or in London
or in a few other centers in Europe like
at least in the USA they used to be
coming from the Bible Belt right from
there usually the people who were born
in a religious source they often were
people who D converted or went for a job
in the coasts and then you know they
become the source of the new Facebook of
the new interesting technology transfer
transformational thing but this sort of
stops happening because there's been a
very very strong decline in number of
child poor women in the vast majority of
Western societies so what's happening
now is the equatorial societies you know
the Indonesians Nigeria and many other
sub-saharan African countries and maybe
some parts of northern Brazil are out
reproducing the other parts and it seems
to me that very few people are thinking
from this perspective of like who are
this the gene pool evolutionary sources
and the gene pool evolutionary sinks
right so San Francisco is a sink people
don't really have kids here and given
they don't have kids here we should
expect you know the gene pool to be
coming from somewhere
it used to be from the Bible Belt now
it's from Nigeria
you know some other Southeast Asian
places and so on and then there's the
question of like okay if this is the
game we're playing extrapolate this game
for a few generations given what we know
about the heritability of psychological
characteristics their ability of a bunch
of other things where do we expect this
to go will society become more notoriety
and less authoritarian more interesting
more valuable etc and I think that that
exercise is really valuable yes and this
framework of thinking about you know
sources and saying why the show is
called simulation that's a very
interesting way to think about it too
with the populations as a sink in San
Francisco there's more dogs here than
right versus in like sub-saharan Africa
we see popular birth rates in five six
still and what developed countries Japan
and the United States and a lot of won
or replacement fertility you have one
child per couple instead of even two so
that's why you see some populations so
that's where the Christianity story
becomes more interesting at least to me
like I was raised non-religious right
I've had a non religious upbringing but
Christianity started being more
interesting and fascinating to me
because as I've studied this more and
more I've grown to think that one of the
main drivers that causes women to have
to be willing to have more children is
to have a culture in a system that is
organized around some type of system of
religious values and then you know
Christianity and Islam are the biggest
one so their religious wants to talk
about but I guess Judaism also does the
same thing and there's other smaller
religious systems that have that that
create that propensity whereas you know
in in most of the of the places that are
you know mimetic sources and genetic
things right so so San Francisco is a
memetic source and a genetic seems
interesting and inversely the Bible Belt
is the is the inverse right it's yes
like if you throw ideas there the idea
is basically like they get they melt and
but if you throw genes in
well people have a lot of kids if you're
with the genes and same thing with like
Nigeria right if you throw interesting
ideas about I don't know complicated
cryptocurrencies down into the Nigerian
population a lot of you too will just
melt down but if you throw your genes in
there there's gonna be a lot of you know
small islands a few generations from now
yeah Oh interesting sources and sinks
and and it's interesting to notice that
they're inverted right the the mean
people and the gene people are kind of
inverted
yeah they aren't that regard they are
yeah you're also passing with
primatology I love bonobos this is konzi
he's the smartest primate that we know
of order in humans and yeah he's famous
for absorbing a lot of linguistic
abilities he can put he can create a
fire and do a lot of interesting tasks a
fire huh create a fire yeah he can
create a fire like you can he can do it
really like skillful stuff oh this is
contact improvisation correct which you
referenced earlier was one of the
reasons you came to hippie Berkeley was
because yes I love dancing I love doing
like rolling around like cuddle puddles
right it's a very fun stuff like to be
all you know loose and dancing and then
kind of like rolling around if people
it's a very important thing to to do
it's really brings you back to you know
humanity yeah less so to these devices
and the IT world and there's a lot of me
that like you know when I go to academic
conferences and stuff I hang out if
people or you know they think that their
body is the entire function of their
bodies is to take their mind to the next
conference and I'm like okay maybe we
should actually just be a little more
monist here you know the body and the
minor one yeah you have to yeah so so
what's happening you know these two
billion Christians you're seeing the
sync and source what and there's that
the main aspect of the super organism
that you're well yes so then we could
also like sector Christianity by the
different parts and then one interesting
thing that I've noticed and that made me
write about it was that the Mormons are
actually the only
group it seems it seems that is still
expanding at a faster rate than the
Muslims who emigrated to Europe so for
people who want the West to continue
being oriented by the set of values that
made possible things like you know
through science seeking of knowledge and
so on one interesting perspective would
be to provide in some way more more
resources and more ability for Mormonism
to keep doing what it has been doing
well so far right so Mormon Mormon moms
have I think on average three point four
kids Muslims in Europe have 2.6 and then
order denominations in the u.s. you know
it varies a fair amount both by by
religion and by racial group and I think
the Mormons might be kind of in a sense
a secret to to creating this desirable
future if there are no transformative
technologies because they are the
highest intelligence group and the
highest level of trust group that is
reproducing at a very fast rate in the
world right now alongside the Ashkenazi
Jews who don't reproduce as fast but
they're pretty smart and they worry they
have more training in a world that is
already globalized right the Ashkenazi
Jews have been globalized for a really
long time and the Mormons are very
expensive because they send missionaries
everywhere and I think that to the
extent that some aspects of what we
value in civilizations some aspects of
like you know the possibility of
creating artificial intelligence the
possibility of creating burningman the
possibility of tolerating atheists the
possibility of tolerating a crazy
counterculture of hippies dancing I
think all of those things they're much
more acceptable within a Christian
framework they're much more acceptable
within a Mormon framework then they are
within an Islamic framework or they are
within like many other religions as well
and therefore you know if we're going to
just steer evolution a little bit maybe
we should just bump the Mormons a little
bit that that was my my intuition and
what I wrote about interesting
interesting so this has to do with
the ability to tolerate new ideas and
has ability to the replacement fertility
3.6 you said something for trough
high-trust high truth there well I don't
know if Mormons are particularly seeking
but there's the question of like who
tolerates best the people who are good
at through the seeking right so salary
truth seekers best because a lot of
truth seekers for instance are atheist
or agnostics and atheists or agnostics
are genetic dead ends right like in
three generations most atheists won't
leave descendants because even if you do
like your children won't and then your
children's children won't so what you
want is there is for there to be a
constant flux of new new population new
people on a particular population saved
Mormons or Christians or something like
that and then a lot of people will
Deacon Verte and they will become the
atheist the the scientist the agnostics
interesting the same thing of the Jewish
groups right there's the the Jewish
groups that are more the docs and less
Orthodox but in order to keep the amount
of liberal Jews that exist
you need the conservative Jews and then
some conservative Jews become liberal
yeah yeah okay so even though you have
like three and a half children per
couple that are Mormon or Jewish or the
practice Islam whatever that one of them
they one of them at least occasionally
will leave that religion or that school
of things just go versus if you only
have half a child per rule then you have
almost you know no chance for your
descendants to pick up right of the
values of truth-seeking and why not yeah
yeah yeah and then and then the reason
why I put the word superorganism there
and that I think that there is value in
thinking of it that way is you know if
you have a super organism of ants right
you have the queen and and you have
soldier ants and they have
specialization and you have worked
entomology
which you're off this is this within
entomology yeah this is just in order to
make the parallel like more valuable so
you know religious religious groups also
have these separations where you have
like a priest class you have a class of
the faith where you have a class that is
more fanatic the more fanatics usually
have more children and so on so within a
religion you have these specializations
but think of you know a Christian
country like the US right it's not true
that everyone is Christian but I think
the the people in the course they're you
can think of them as nomadic soldiers
yes right so there are the people who
are not the reproductive lineage the
Bible Belt is the queen they're
producing the new gene pool of like new
humans and some of them branch out to
the coast where they learn more about
the mimetics and participate in that
right and some of them even come to
california and then tell the entire rest
of society that actually you know
they're all millionaires and they should
adopt a bunch of ideas that make them
have fewer children and then they have
fewer children which is very interesting
like I think California in a sense kind
of a soldier that is decreasing the
population of the other super organisms
in the world which is the Psalter of
biological lens is so interesting yeah
yes so the read the queen the queen bee
the reproducer in the you know in an
entomological view this is so
interesting yeah where are the workers
where the reproducer is where the
mimetics the driver sorcerer's right you
have to think of which frequency do you
want of which group and what are the
groups that are most likely in the
future to generate the frequencies you
want so so let me let's say something
that is dear to me right I'm seeing like
there's a picture of Burning Man behind
you right and Burning Man is a very dear
thing to me I want Burning Man to go on
for as long as possible but I know that
the kind of person who goes to Burning
Man is not likely to have children and
that Burning Man is definitely like a
sink for like some of those weirdos in
different societies so I want to make
sure that there are more Mormons because
some of those Mormons will D convert to
a less fanatical version of Christianity
some of those Christians will D converts
to a more liberal crazy chaotic thing
and these are the people who will keep
Burning Man going whereas if I was in a
society where there was more strict
authoritarian values saying like kurgans
Turkey it would be
more troublesome because you know there
can be a crack now from that kind of
society which prevents people from even
being atheist in their in their ID being
Christian in their ID that kind of thing
and it could also prevent the sorts of
fun hippies that I like to hang out with
from existing in the future which I
would be sad about so the ability to
tolerate ideas and this is so important
and you this invented ways as you look
at it through an entomological lens I'm
also looking at it through a codified
lens of you know which code do you want
to continue propagating what new code
deployments do you want to push out into
civilization and where are the sources
of these code deployments and the
sources of the genetics of the babies
that are being born this is some very
very very very good
ok now what about the mythological ties
you gave you I think you were talking
about it a little bit earlier but and
how that relates to morality how that
relates to the individual right we see a
lot of the university heroes or heroines
journey stories that are occurring yeah
so it seems to me that society is waking
up now to the psychological value of a
lot of what before we just had like
automatized in our psychological systems
and I guess you know the main person by
very by a very large distance was doing
this job is Jordan Peterson with is like
biblical lectures and with his teachings
that are being very enticing let's say
to a young man to rethink about the
narrative of how they're going to live
so I think these this is a very valuable
effort and what I was talking about is
what I expected to be like the next
stage of that is that people will
realize that there's value only not only
psychological but also evolutionary in
terms of like these population dynamics
you know attack and defense and other
things that if you're thinking of a
beehive there's that perspective but
going back into the psychological into
the psychological framework for for
thinking of these things I think
we've had a crisis of meaning which I
guess Nietzsche was one of the main
people who indicated it by the saying
that God is dead but you know his shadow
will live 4000 years where we didn't
really know what to do as a society
after the death of God and this created
a propensity for a rise into going back
into a last mythological less religious
narrative and a more biological ratio
kin narrative which is what moved a lot
of the movements that were troublesome
in the 20th century and ended up killing
a bunch of people and this rise of
collectivism seems to be one of the
possible events that happens when
there's a fall in systems of meaning and
religiosity that organize people around
so so to me what happened was you know
the Christians per organism in the West
let's say it lost a lot of its power and
in virtue of it losing a lot of its
power it created the conditions whereby
people reverted to a more traditional
tribal mode of operation and that mode
of operation led to things like you know
not Nazism in order forms of
collectivism such as some extensions of
Marxism right were you still have the
collectivism although it's not in lines
of race it's a collectivism lines of
like nation you know the Soviet Union
should be one thing
so I think that there's this trade-off
between meaning and mythos and how
meaning and methods are able to function
as a guide for one specific primate to
organize psychologically how they're
going to decide through life to go
through things and then if that kind of
diminishes on the other side of the
trade or if you have a rise of
collectivism which is well there's
someone who's telling me you know this
is the group of which you are part of
that you should care more most about so
you know care about yourself in virtue
of being a Brazilian in virtue of being
a an Armenian and then you know
sometimes the Armenian Genocide happens
which isn't really great so that that
kind of thing
has been very problematic throughout the
20th century in many parts of the world
so then what is part of you know what
you're describing here is how do how do
we take what you're describing and
synthesize it to what could be like the
best code from the you know the mythos
and the meaning as well as the the
collective you know potential thinking
on that we have as well how can those
two write so I mean for one thing it
seems that you know if the arguments
that Peterson has been putting forth are
right and a few other innovation areas
apologists and thinkers are right it
seems that the the reason why the
biblical stories for instance evolved is
because they are a very adaptive system
a very effective system to make
to make individuals reason their way
through life
in a way that eventually creates a
stable and unified and functional
Society right so you think of having as
a metaphor in in that if you behave you
know in a biblical way and if you figure
out how to like slay your dragon and get
the the Treasury and you come back to
your tribe and your shared Treasury
which is a lot of what the biblical
stories reveal let's say and if you live
in a walled garden that that kind of
thing if that's the psychology that is
guiding your actions you end up creating
a society that has positive
transformation yes yes so in this this
starts with the simple you know waking
up in the morning you know you're you're
doing gratitude you're you know making
your bed you're stretching your body
like even prayer I mean prayer can be
thought of as a visualization of a
destiny that you want which is a very
fascinating way of getting to they're
getting to their correct and correct so
this is this potential that this what do
we what do we take as the central ethos
and stories that can help individuals
with the practices everyday that
automatically will make a better a
better world um
okay and then this I mean what we were
just talking about also has to do with
this crisis of meaning that is currently
occurring and one of the things that has
come in to help with the crisis meeting
is potentially these these lectures and
these intellectuals that have come in
and said we think that if you start with
your own self and start with practicing
these these habits and yourself that you
can help your family help your community
help the world and so there is also kind
of a weird things happening with the the
fertility rates that are decreasing in
places like Japan you actually said it
was a panic ation right yeah I call it
Joe Penna fication yeah and I think it's
a process that's also happening in the
West right where if yeah we're reducing
populations pretty much everywhere and I
think that has a lot to do with you know
the the californian memes being spread
all over the world into societies where
they're not necessarily adaptive anymore
you know thinking that everyone can be
like a liberal individual libertarian
millionaire who organizes their
lives around like cybernetic stuff and
information theory and and thinks in
those ways yeah you tell that to people
in different societies they're going to
stop living in the ways that made their
genes like go on and that made their
population stable and that created you
know a stable society for them so yeah I
think there's a there's some trouble in
there Japan efficacious might be the
version there where it's you know it's
only one country it's less influenced by
that kind of culture but it's a
separation of the sexes just because the
two sexes have different incentives
whereas what I think is happening in the
West it's like it's that but on top of
that there is also an incentivized
promotion of like people no longer
forming families are no longer creating
the conditions for you know a stable
population over time and we're gonna
talk to Katie about this on the next
show but the the code here seems to be
in some ways that like we're talking
about journey's beginning this
interdependent capitalism seems to take
potentially some more of this original
source code of these by of biological
kin that this mother this love
unconditional love and taking it that's
why you see when you when you're walking
with sometimes a stranger you you know
you're trying to have an altruistic
interaction but it doesn't happen right
though the code hasn't scaled to that to
that degree and I think maybe some of
the some of the code that's caused and
we were talking about earlier about the
families not being potentially as
important mimetic sources potentially
make it you you aim to climb up this
hierarchy of a mimetic source there's no
time for genetics
there's no time for procreation yeah and
women are trying to climb up that same
hierarchy to of mimetics
and the corporation's want people to not
have time for biology and to not have
time to keep the gene pool being one
that's like hydras high intelligence
high-value people or you know organize
or who organize I mean the corporation's
want that the state wants that the the
entire system is designed
reducing the propensity of the people
who could create the most positive
society from dedicating themselves to
genes and then incentivizing them to
dedicating themselves either to dopamine
hits or to means yeah those are the two
things for which society is being you
know twist that the high levels of
society are being twisted right so so
this so let's give them let's give it
let's see let's see if I can do a little
quick paraphrase as well so on the on
the mimetic sources there's there's at
the same time there's the desire to want
to spread memes to billions of people
which is very interesting it can augment
civilization interesting ways but then
if you're not a memetic sorcerer
sometimes you can fall into the the dope
the constant urge for dopamine from
videogames from drugs right and that can
be that also takes people away from
finding meaning finding creating value
into the world through genetic
procreation so that takes away from
procreation speak for yourself
drugs work for me how many children did
they produce yeah my family and then and
then let's take let's take into the on
that on that genetics on the high
genetic on the high procreation side of
things why why would you say then is a
the incentive structure that that we
have today what what is what's what's
happening with the the government and
the private entities the corporations
that want the that don't want why is
there a strong desire for you know they
want more productive workers they want
they don't want them focused as much on
on family and and when there's less
babies there's like there's it's a kind
of weird thing cuz right when you want a
kid you also get another mind to kind of
mold into the world so what they also
potentially want but a human labor can
be less effective than a robotic labor
yeah in a world where there was
sufficient homogeneity of pretty much
right if every land if every land piece
was homogeneous if every nation was
homogeneous if every if there was zero
inequality in the world then they would
be in favor of families but what happens
is that we live in a world where you can
get the benefits that were generated by
by the biomes of like different
countries by the super organisms of
different religions and different
systems without necessarily having to
pay the costs so why would I want to pay
your salary to be good enough for you to
sustain your wife and two children if I
can instead hire you know whoever turns
out in the entire population of India to
be one of the best ten computer
scientists right so I as a corporation
have an interest in keeping some level
of open borders so that I can bring in
whatever turns out to be the best of
that selection pool whilst at the same
time kind of like keeping your your
partner fee and then I get the best
people from literally every country in
the world and I make them stop having
kids which is what the USA kind of does
I mean the USA is great in many ways
this is one of the things that it does
that is a little bit more problematic
because ten generations from now you
know the Flynn effect is also doing this
thing where you know IQ went up for
quite a while mostly due to nutrition
but now it's definitely gonna go down
because you know the people who are
producing the most by very far in the
world average IQ or it's like 70 80 85
yeah like and individually right it's
not it's not just a matter of average
within countries between countries
everywhere right it's idiocracy like
that movie yeah that I've never seen but
everyone tells me about so what so one
of the major problems you just pointed
at is that a lot of the highest the
highest the highest IQ or the highest
like most abstract thinkers about
civilization the ones that are actually
moving the next ways that that betters
our world into coded into action these
people aren't having kids right that is
yeah that is one problem there is
well it's not just it's not just the the
the fact that there is this divergence
between different parts in the world in
terms of salary right it's worthwhile
for someone to come from from India to
here but also there's the the woman
question that you mentioned which is
like you know do I want my workforce to
lose a bunch of people who are going to
be stay-at-home moms and taking care of
their babies or do I want to get women
to be as productive as possible and then
I have to pay half a salary instead yeah
yeah yeah and then the Oh men they can
continuing productive meanwhile you
continue sourcing the best talent from
around the world from those from those
met local maximums across the world
because you have the most money you're
the largest super organism this very
much so seems like Google trying to
maybe monopolize the substrate that
everybody uses and just continues to
right there yeah it's it's a it's a
monopoly on who gets to suction the best
genes without that much of occurrence of
care for the future from both the big
corporations and some of the big states
that are magnets you know state magnets
that are states that are so awesome that
everyone wants to move to them I'm not
like I did like like my like you know
yeah a monopoly suction of the best
genes yeah yeah yeah yeah and not yeah
this is this is this is a very we've
outsourced reproduction to different
parts of the world and in doings in
doing this outsourcing what happens is
that the externalities of that are not
being taken into account and they are
deferred to future generations who are
not going to have you know as many
valuable creators and high conscientious
people and so on as the our generation
had yeah okay couple you know quick
quick things on the way out I know you
have a you have an argument against
effective altruism which I think's or
it's a crop in fact of all I think is
great and I think an interesting
argument for for it that I think still
stands though right is that you can
either spend your time going immediately
to a place in the world that desperately
needs attention and going in using your
human labor hours there
you can do things like earn the
financial means in a developed part of
the world to do five times as much
impact in that area of the world so
there this is the idea of how effective
is the altruism that is being delivered
how do we quantify that and measure that
and so there is there's now it's now
grown to become a super organism in some
ways that is small organism let's say
that has yeah more corruption yeah I
think what happened with what happened
in Thea is there's been two processes
that made effective altruism worse than
what it was before right so when we when
we conceived of it when it created of it
it was very exciting there were a lot of
very good people who are trying to you
know as quickly as possible deliver as
many goods as possible in terms of
trying to theorize and architect a
movement that was going to make the
world a better place but the most
effective means possible right that was
great
and then the two problems that I see
with it is there wasn't once there's an
influx of resources be that you know in
this in the state be that in a
corporation or be that in an NGO or in a
set of NGOs like it's the case in fact
about tourism you have the interest of
whoever's like bringing in that money
and you also have people who are trying
to ring ring fans the money in order to
like foster their own causes and kind of
corrupt the system in that way so what
happened in the a was the the a lot of
the best people who were the original
creators of the movement kind of
separated themselves from me and started
dedicating themselves to like far future
stuff crucial considerations to
artificial general intelligence and
separated themselves at this from a
brand perspective from yeh which already
left the movement kind of like hanging
down a little bit and then there's the
secondary process where if you're if
you're pumping money into an entity
whatever it is you know the state the
core the corpse and so on
people who don't have sufficiently much
competency that they would create be
creating a lot of value try to capture
that value on its way in and on its way
out
and I
think in the in the case of yeh there's
been a lot of similarity between what
happened to EI and what happened to the
Democratic Party of the USA wait meaning
that the the poverty related causes in a
the the National related causes in a
ended up becoming kind of a platform of
the Democratic Party
so what before was like okay let's find
the most impactful neglected intractable
causes in the world and invest in them
now it's like well there's this person
who works for one of the organization's
that's being sponsored by one of the
like Facebook billionaires and in doing
so like they're distributing resources
for dissing cars for incarcerated people
in Florida to get the vote and it's like
who cares if the incarcerated people in
Florida get default or don't get the
vote given that there might be 10 to the
32 people into the far future if life is
on the biological ten to the fifty one
if it's computational and like when
there's so many different ways in which
you could intervene if things like
schistosomiasis control malaria control
and so on in the in the present world
right even if you are present chauvinist
right even if you pretend the future
doesn't exist which is an absurd flaws
of composition if you ask me but even if
we pretend that there were still much
better investments to do than that and I
think he got corrupted on those lines
yeah yeah
to be able to continuously measure the
efficacy of what we're delivering and
would focus on it's very hard because
the people who are bringing in the money
they bring us like sometimes are the
same people who are bringing in the
corruption right that's that's just
crazy yeah yeah
the yeah yeah okay let's um let's ask
you about the lot you know you were
targeting this in the last part as well
this AI safety and security you know
there's this is exploding as you know
you talk about this in front and as well
in your content where you where you say
that if if we just think that we just
leave this alone the malevolent
characters that are the democratized
cost malevolent characters can still
take off with it so AI safety Security's
a lot about making sure that the
malevolence cannot occur right well I
think I mean AI safety has been the
thing that I dedicated most of my early
adulthood to right so for about ten
years I was dedicating to effective
altruism to movements and etc but within
those and emphasis on the far future
within the far future an emphasis on
crucial considerations and within
crucial considerations an emphasis on AI
just because I think that from an impact
perspective AI is the the it's the one
that if we solve that problem it's going
to reduce dramatically the magnitude of
a lot of the other problems that could
happen so out of all the existential
risks that could come to pass
AI is the one that deletes most of the
other ones and therefore one of the most
valuable ones and it's also one that
seems more actionable you know it's kind
of it's not very easily actionable to
work on like brain scanning like either
it will become a neuromorphic
problematic thing or it won't but they
are aiding AI you can actually use
technical human knowledge to try and and
help it out I don't I don't think that
malevolence of humans is the main worry
that we should be having any I at least
if we're talking about super
intelligence you know artificial general
intelligence because there are
sufficiently many technical problems
that just getting the the technicality
right
maybe governance problems might be more
relevant in terms of like how they make
sure that in
the polar world were many different
agents were many different artificial
intelligences are operating against each
other how do you prevent evolutionary
conflict between them that will create
the types of incentives that will make
one of the players kind of you know cast
a very negative spell very early on in
the game that could compromise all the
value of the future so I do think that
we should think about AI from the
perspective of governance but I think
about it more in terms of systems and
last in terms of like dr. evil is
planning the AI in his basement or
something like that yeah having some
centralized control is actually good
right I tend to I have become much more
more conservative and more right-leaning
but this is a case where I go in the
other direction and I'm more of a
statist like left-leaning
movement because I want there to be more
centralized control of who has the
ability of creating an AI and in the
current world only states are big enough
you know to to yeah that kind of thing
and why not use some of this data fusion
technology these little credit score
technologies where you just don't get
access to a gun or artificial
intelligence or synthetic biology or
whatever the disastrous potential may be
if you have had a previous record of
significant malevolence I mean oh right
that's the centralized argument side of
things and worse and there is a little
centralized community that maintains
like the Bitcoin core rights of the
etherium core these are little groups
that you have to work your way up in
terms of cryptography and blockchain
technologies to in order to write their
stake yeah there's some sort of like
credibility system that basically pumps
the right people to the talk and what we
what we want in terms of morality and
like reorganizing the people who are
already like they've given up on
genetics and they're only living in the
main space for those people I think what
we want is to align the incentives of
you know Fame and capitalism and power
as much as possible with morality and
with creating a good future so that
would be you know
anyway - yeah your your fifth boat or
fifth gold watch is just you know it's
not gonna add any value to your life
anymore it's see ya they enter depending
capitalism is yeah that's that's a case
where we actually want to like remove
the evolutionary incentive right we have
this evolutionary desire from signaling
to everyone exactly like okay so make it
know if signaled enough you know like
yeah we can signal a little less
Instagram fleets have gone ridiculous
yeah promoting that type of behavior and
making that the incentive and and
addressing teenage girls young people
and yeah yeah gee this has been super
fun I want to ask you two questions on
the way out okay all right this is
simulation so we have to ask you are we
in a simulation I I take the same
response as Bostrom I don't talk about
my probability of us being in a
simulation in public because I think it
can be misinterpreted by people in many
different ways but yeah there is a
probability and I I think I sign a
higher probability than most people
would okay yeah I do say this is
probably the safest place for you to not
be misinterpreted with this question
fair enough yeah yeah I mean I I buy the
simulation argument right so the
simulation hypothesis the hypothesis
that we are but the simulation argument
is one of those three things is true you
probably are familiar that you know
either
we won't create simulated civilizations
or we will restrict their number
enormous ly or we will you know we will
create them and then most people who are
in what most people already are in one
or will destroy ourselves before we were
able to do it to begin with so I do
assign some some probability mass to
being a simulation yeah for one thing it
would increase my chances of immortality
which sounds great
ah you know yeah if I'm if I'm just the
ape that most people think I am odds are
yeah yeah yeah that you're less likely
to be immortal yeah there's there's a
limit at the edge not well yeah that I'm
less likely to be long
long lived the first million years is
what counts so yeah and there's a whole
slew of other areas to go with the whole
infinite infinite beings and where we go
pre birth and post death and that clear
there was a lot of fun about the
metaphysics of that yeah yeah yeah okay
and then last question is what is the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most beautiful thing in the world
I I think I would go for like something
enveloped within an otter thing and
developed within another thing so maybe
something like after a delicious
conversation with friends reading a Nick
Bostrom paper over a pyramid at Burning
Man before before the sunset that sounds
like a good combination of things yeah
so that's the that would be a beautiful
experience yeah yeah I like the idea of
enveloping Beauty in different kinds of
beauty so yeah yeah yeah you took a very
meta person every method typed in so
many different things into the yeah
that's great yeah I think I think
complexity is one of the valuable things
are on in the universe that generates a
lot of beauty I love complexity yeah
yeah you're you must be a great romantic
I do it that whole I'm an incorrigible
romantic as you might find out in the
next interview a good thank you so so
much for coming onto the show we greatly
appreciate it yeah there was a lot of
carry very good wisdom unpack Tara wrong
thank you very much guys yes yes thank
you everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know what you're thinking go and have
more conversations with other people
above all was talked about here huge
shot up to you round Vegas thank you for
producing and directing we love them
very much also everyone support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in you know diego's links are
below simulations links are below
support them let them flourish help them
flourish and go and build the future
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you so much and we will see you
soon peace
[Music]